another game it's are pretty soon you've
been playing for a couple of weeks now I
feel like everyone in the office been
playing a little bit of us we had a
Marrakech been playing us okay they did
some live streams couple weeks back but
Dark Souls 3 yeah you're a fan tell me
your Dark Souls lineage do you go all
the way back to demon souls are worthy
to come into this so basically like a
blood-borne fan and that's about it okay
so aside from demon souls have beaten
all the from games at least twice
blood-borne although it's probably my
it's one of my favorite from software
games now it's probably the one at being
the fewest times aside from demon souls
demon souls I'd be once back in the day
went through it almost twice but I never
I never completely finished like a new
game plus but yeah I've had a sense of I
think dark souls 1 was my first one
right I went to two went back to demon
souls blood-borne was my game of the
year last year what's your favorite um
probably blood-borne rise point we're
disregarding my review impressions on
Dark Souls 3 probably blood-borne at
this point yeah cool yeah diceless
disregarding cuz you can't talk about it
yet yeah talk about it what Tuesday
Tuesday yeah week from now despite the
fact that everyone's streaming it online
right now yeah we can't talk about the
US version what I think of that until so
talk to me about the japanese version
beshte has been at that we've been able
to uh yeah it's it's as if I keep
telling people that it's as if Dark
Souls 1 and blood-borne kind of had a
baby okay it's it's very much like I
blade through my first playthrough
without a shield the whole time which
you know blood-borne was but twitchy er
I was more of a knife fight as opposed
to this like boxing match I don't know
but it's it's more of a you can dodge
very much more often faster I just
poured it into endurance which helps you
dodge more and strength I start with a
warrior went got through most the bosses
Eric hey has gotten he's fought I think
a few more Boston I have for sure he's
gone to these secret areas and I've been
mean to go back to since I finished the
game the first time and I need to do
that soon but I have a lot of other
projects as we all do going on so I'm
trying to balance that out because I
want to get through the japanese version
as well which is I'm kind of it's weird
because they swap the Dodge and the
action button so I trouble hi
yeah yeah so I'm gonna be tapping circle
and wondering why I'm just still getting
hit at teen toaster 1132 says i love the
lower in story parts of the souls games
of blood-borne how you enjoying that
aspect of it so far it's just as obscure
as they always have been but this one
does a pretty good job of setting up the
overall structure your kind of the Lords
of cinder their 51 who well without
spoiling anything there are five largest
cinder and then certain number of them
have like abandoned their Thrones for a
little bit so you're just hunting them
down to kind of link the fire which is a
common theme trope and dark souls you
know there's the age of fire the age of
darkness it's you have to really look
deep into this lore if you want to get
much out of it but I think for people
who don't care as much the story does a
good job of structurally setting up what
you're doing like a Zelda game kind of
your hunting out these bosses these four
there's not just for bosses in Dark
Souls to be but there are four major
ones and then beside from that is very
obscure and still it's it's more about
tone the next position I think and this
nails a tone just like the other ones
have it seems like anyone who's a fan of
Souls game at this age is already sort
of chomping at the bit for this one of
these two things I found about
blood-borne was that it appeals to I
don't know what it is about like
resetting a franchisor like starting a
new one over it's a little less of a
barrier to entry for people like I
played Bob blood-borne and I felt a lot
easier to get into then I think I was
imagining dark souls to be do you think
Dark Souls 3 would be a good place for
people to start who maybe have skipped
out in the first two in Demon's Souls
yeah I actually like I think I was
telling Pete because Pete said he's been
wanting to get into these games for a
long time yeah you want you've not
played much of them right so I play a
lot of demon souls I didn't finish it
tried playing dark souls and sort of the
same problem i had with blood-borne same
problem i think a lot of people have
where they beat their head against the
wall trying to like you know learn the
game and get good at it you know you
make a bunch of progress and then you
hit another wall right yeah and it's
that instance where you felt like he
made some progress and hit another wall
that for me was just too much but that's
you know time for me is really precious
if it was something like I had more time
or it was an assignment i would love to
really focus in on that but for dark
souls 3 i'm really going to try this
time i'm going to make it happen because
i really like blood-borne and I'd kind
of let that pass me by I still need to
go back and Finn
that you know and for what you've told
me this sounds like it's a good way to
get into the series for a lot of people
yeah either if you're completely new to
it or if like even more so if blood
borns one that got you into it this is
probably the Dark Souls weirdly enough
the third the trilogy to get into it
with because it's I think it I didn't
find it it's still difficult I hit walls
but maybe it was just because I was kind
of plowing through it over a course of a
few days whereas blood-borne I let
trickle over two or three weeks and I
mean once you've played that you know
this is like the fifth of these games
right it's not like the same first time
you played any of them yeah I think it
does also like you know it's really good
in that in terms of directing you where
to go Dark Souls people like the first
Dark Souls because you start off and
there's like four different directions
you go right away it's kind of
overwhelming you have to learn where
you're going to get killed a ton and
then where you're actually going to get
killed only a few times and that's the
way you go this one kind of balances
giving you options but not too many so I
think the most paths I could take at any
one time was three or four but then
there were never less than two most of
the time so it like I felt like I could
explore but I didn't feel like I was
being completely overwhelmed so I think
in that respect it's always like
structurally this might be the game to
get into also a lot of people into
chatter talking about how it's been
running on PC what have you been playing
on mostly what are the guys live stream
on actually as well they live streamed
on pc i believe okay i was playing on
ps4 and i noticed some hiccups but i
don't know like whether I'd speak that
until it's closer to launch I'm sure
that I'd like a patch for it you know
what Eric was saying that they have a
day one patch which is hoping to resolve
some of the frame rate he stuff but yeah
ps4 was looking all right um there were
definite framerate issues um which like
you said the patch hopefully fixed that
pc it's not locked at 30 like a console
is okay so you can you can jack it up
the frame rate I notice on people
playing a PC the frame right look
completely fine it looked great any
other technical issues there you know
just minor here and there nothing huge
but yeah I think pending that patch I'd
rather play it on pc right just because
it's a game that requires precision I
don't want frame rates ever be an issue
like that one second i'm going to miss a
dodge or something yeah fair enough at
dark souls 3 is out in japan as of april
tough or sorry march 24
but adds at April 12 here in North
America and in the rest of the world in
Europe as well and the rest of the world
the North America while you folks in
Zealand in Africa look forward to Dark
Souls 3 coming out in a couple of weeks
when is the review embargo dropping them
a week from today oh really at some
point alright so next week a week ahead
of time that's good thank you so much
Michael my hearty getting I said the
lowdown on this visual game
you